an historic Maryland city is under state
of emergency after powerful flash
flooding devastated its downtown
torrential rain sent water rushing into
Ellicott City yesterday for the second
time in less than two years the water
approached the second floor of buildings
and swept away cars first responders
rescued dozens of people one person is
missing this morning Jeff bagasse is in
Ellicott City just west of Baltimore
Jeff good morning good morning rescue
crews work through the night after
yesterday's flooding and now they are
searching for this missing person they
do not have a lot to go on but they are
hopeful this was another devastating
flood take a look behind me at this
parking lot which is on the edge of Main
Street there are more than a dozen cars
caked in mud some overturned the flash
flood came in with a roar Sunday turning
Main Street and Ellicott City Maryland
into a raging river the fast-moving
water quickly swept away cars and
carried debris down the usually busy
Main Street as the flooding began Sunday
police had a stern warning for those
trying to drive through the high water
hole lower level is under water in some
buildings the flood waters rose past the
first floor leaving people scrambling
for higher ground actually no a lot of
people that work down here and a lot of
them were trapped on like the second and
third storey it floors because they
couldn't get out they say this is a once
every thousand year flood and we had two
of them in two years Ellicott City is
still reeling from a catastrophic 2016
flood that killed two people decimated
Main Street and cost around 20 million
dollars in damage I don't think I'm
without exaggeration saying that this is
worse than July 30th of 2016 now less
than two years later the scene here is
eerily similar to July of 2016 I can
just tell you my heart is broken
thinking about what the people are going
through here they rebuilt and now
they're faced with the same daunting
task again
they are marking up these cars a sign
that they are a total loss about two
weeks ago Maryland's governor announced
a 1 million dollar FEMA reward to help
reduce the risk of flooding also
recently officials announced that 96
percent of the businesses affected by
the flooding two years ago and reopen
their doors but this flooding once again
as raised doubts here about the future
be honest stunning images let's hope
they find that missing resident Jeff
thank you